- [Voiceover] It's super
valuable in biological systems
to be able to take a glucose molecule
and to phosphorylate it.
So let's start with a glucose molecule
and phosphorylate it, and the reason why
is once you have this phosphate group--
let me make sure I put that
charge right over there.
Once you have this phosphate group,
or once you have this negative charge
on this glucose six phosphate,
it becomes much harder
for it to leave the cell.
The cell wants to hog as many
glucose molecules as it can.
When the glucose isn't charged,
it's able to pass through
the cellular membrane,
but then once it becomes phosphorylated,
it's going to stay in the cell.
And glucose six phosphate right over here,
this is a very important input
to a whole series of
processes inside of cells.
Now unfortunately, this reaction
of taking glucose and phosphorylating it,
it requires energy, it's endergonic,
it's not going to happen spontaneously.
It has a positive delta-G.
It is ender, ender,
it is endergonic.
And so you can imagine
what we're going to need
to make it happen.
We're going to have to use the
energy currency of the cell,
our good friend ATP.
And the way that we're going
to make this reaction happen
is we're going to couple
what's essentially,
you could view it as a hydrolysis of ATP,
although we won't have
exactly a water molecule
in the mechanism,
but what's functionally
the hydrolysis of ATP
into ADP and a phosphate group.
Which is very energetically favorable.
It is exergonic,
it would happen spontaneously
under the right conditions.
It won't just always happen
inside of an solution,
it needs a little bit of
activation energy or an enzyme
to lower the activation energy,
but the net reaction, it is exergonic.
So what we can do is we can
couple these two reactions.
And so when we couple the two reactions,
when we couple the two reactions,
we have ATP,
ATP plus glucose,
plus glucose,
reacting,
and we use an enzyme,
the general term for it is hexokinase,
to facilitate this reaction,
to lower the activation energy,
it's going to yield, it's going to yield
glucose six phosphate, glucose,
glucose-6-phosphate,
phosphate,
and ADP.
And ADP.
A-D-P.
Now what's the delta-G for
this reaction going to be?
Well it's a coupled
reaction, you can view it
as a combination of these two reactions,
and so roughly speaking you can say,
well, let's just add the delta-G's.
So if you add the delta-G's here,
you're going to get,
if you add this negative delta-G,
this exergonic and this positive delta-G,
you're gonna get -30.5 plus 13.8,
that's going to be -16.7 kilojules,
kilojules per mol.
And so this coupled reaction
is going to be exergonic.
Not quite as exergonic as hydrolysis,
because now you're gonna be
using some of that energy,
but this can happen spontaneously,
especially if you can lower
the activation energy enough
for it to happen.
And so let's now look at the mechanism
of how it happens.
Now without an enzyme, without an enzyme,
the way that this reaction needs to occur
is that you have an electron,
you have an electron pair right over here
on this hydroxyl group,
and it needs to do what's
called a nucleophilic attack
on this phosphorous right over here.
But without an enzyme, it's
gonna be very hard for it to do.
It's gonna have a high activation energy
because it's going to be
impaired by all of this
negative charge from these
oxygens right over here.
You can imagine, electrons don't like
going through a lot of negative charge,
they're repulsed by negative charge.
So we're gonna need an enzyme
to help facilitate this reaction,
to help lower the energy
to actually start it.
Essentially get these
electrons out of the way.
And the enzyme, or the general term
for the enzymes that do
this, is called hexokinase.
And hexokinase, let me write this down.
Hexokinase.
And the way it does it
is it provides ions to,
one way to think about it is to
keep these electrons over here busy.
And in particular, it has a magnesium ion,
a magnesium ion,
right over here,
and this is bound to the
rest of the hexokinase.
Remember, this is all
happening in three dimensions,
So the hexokinase is
kinda wrapping around it,
so these can keep these electrons busy,
there's other ions on the hexokinase
that can keep these electrons busy,
other positive ions keep
these electrons busy.
And so these electrons can sneak in
and do the nucleophilic attack.
Remember, when we talk about enzymes
these are these protein, these protein,
let me do the same color that
I wrote the hexokinase in.
These are these complex protein structures
right over here, just like this,
and so you might have the magnesium ion,
and let me do that in that purple color.
Just right over there, and then
maybe the glucose molecule,
the glucose molecule gets
bound right over here,
and then maybe you have your ATP,
it gets bound right, right over here,
and I'm obviously, I'm just kind of
giving you an example,
this isn't exactly what's happening.
But by essentially wrapping
it with this positive charge,
it's able to pull the electrons away
to help facilitate this
nucleophilic attack
that needs to happen for
the reaction to proceed.
And so this bond right over here
between this oxygen and this phosphorous,
that is going to be,
that is going to be this
bond right over here,
and as this happens, then this character,
then these two electrons can
be taken by this character,
and so this oxygen
is this oxygen right over here,
and now has a negative charge.
And so what we've just resulted with
is glucose-6-phosphate and ADP.
And ADP.
And it's energetically favorable,
it's exergonic.
It's going to happen,
assuming that you have the enzyme there
to help distract these electrons,
lowering the activation energy.
And I know what you're thinking,
we had this hydrogen right over here,
so this hydrogen should
be right over here still,
and then another water molecule could come
and nab the proton, the hydrogen proton,
and so you're left once again
with just the glucose-6-phosphate.
So this, hopefully this gives you a sense
of how reaction coupling occurs,
and also a sense of how
ATP is actually useful.
When I first learned about ATP, I'm like,
okay, fine,
it's, you know, it really wants to let go
of this phosphate group,
it's energetically favorable,
but how is that actually used to,
to drive things, to actually do,
to do things in the system
that might not be energetically favorable.
And hopefully this gives you
a sense of how it's done,
and also the importance of an enzyme
in facilitating it.